vers 19h30 la veille de l'audition
d'olivier véran les sénateurs reçoivent
ainsi plus de 5000 documents des
fichiers que l'administration a mis un
mois et demi à fournir au sénat nos
administrateurs ici au sénat les ont
reçus très très tardivement une très
grand nombre de documents ce qui ne nous
a pas empêchés quand même pendant la
nuit de les examiner d'assez près pour
en faire une certaine classification et
puis pour se rendre compte qu'en effet
aucun était le côté il y avait les
documents qui montrent est effectivement
ce recours exponentielle et cette
intrusion en fait de consultants de
cabinets privés dans la prise de
décisions stratégiques et politiques et
c'est là où le bât blesse et je pense
que ça c'est le coeur le coeur du le
coeur du sujet là nous avons l'exemple
d'un livrables de ma cuisse est qu en
date du 23 août 2000 21 qui fait un
bilan des injections vaccinales
réalisation date qui établit des
projections sur la vaccination pour
atteindre la cible de 50 millions de
primo vaccination que le gouvernement
s'était fixé en septembre
2021 donc ma première question est
simple c'est quel a été le rôle de
mckinsey dans l'établissement de ses
projections vaccinale par exemple en
septembre 2021 ce ne sont pas des
livrables pardonnez moi ce sont des
documents internes au ministère qui
relève des équipes du ministère et
auquel mckinsey a participé vous nous
avez dit que ces documents que se
remontre est un document qui a été
réalisé par les services du ministère
notamment
ma question est simple est-ce que ma qui
est intervenu sur l'élaboration de ce
document mckinsey faisait à renforcer
l'ensemble des équipes en charge de la
politique vaccinale est donc ce n'est
pas un document mckinsey êtes un an et
j'ai bien précisé je me suis fait un
document du ministère ps j'ai mal que
celle intervenue je vous réponds que
mckinsey a contribué à ces documents
donc il est intervenu ils sont cons ils
ont ainsi
constaté
aucun problème avec ça fera précisé un
petit peu les choses qu'on ait fait on
est au commission denquête il faut que
les définitions se précise on entend
bien
la société mckinsey a participé à
l'élaboration du document mais dans quel
cadre à ce moment là parce que
normalement quand on passe une un
contrat avec une société de conseil on
lui confie une mission quelle qu'elle
remplit de façon satisfaisante ou pas
c'est l'administration qui apprécie mais
vous nous dites là que ces gens là
étaient en renfort donc c'était est-ce
que c'était simplement une prestation de
complément ou est ce qu'il y avait une
commande précise d'un mac kinsey
d'abord on parle d'une situation qui est
absolument exceptionnel et documents que
vous montrez sont des documents qui
rendent compte de façon visuelle de tout
ou partie des indicateurs dont nous
disposons ces documents sont réalisés
par les équipes du ministère et nous
avons eu besoin dans cette période de
campagne vaccinale de renforcer les
effectifs de nos équipes par des
prestataires issus de ce cabinet de
conseil qui sont venus avec leurs
propres compétences renforcer les
équipes nous essayons de cadres et de
comprendre quels niveaux d'intervention
du cabinet de conseil mckinsey en
l'occurrence et quel est le niveau
d'apport de l'administration et à aucun
moment le ministre ne nous répondra là
dessus il nous dira en restant
extrêmement vague que c'est un document
de l'administration l'autre c'est grosso
modo le travail de l'administration avec
l'aide de mckinsey mais à 10 % à 90 % on
n'en saura jamais rien
[Musique]